foreign
[Music]
bio and today I'm going to present to
you salt stocks and rock and roll cell
validation and drug and use liver injury
using a human liver MPS
I'm going to talk about
microphysiological systems in general
and what they are then I'm gonna talk to
you about the MPS and in research as
well as in the market and obviously I'm
going to present to you CN bios MPS and
then we're going to go into cell
validation and the drug induced liver
toxicity it's called deadly
so microphysiological systems it's any
what what is it it's in vitro platform
composed of cells explants derived from
tissue organs and an organized cell
formation of human or animal origin in a
microenvironment that provides and
supports biochemical electric or
mechanical responses to model a set of
specific properties that define organ
tissue function so in a nutshell cells
from tissue organs or organoids origin
can be human or animal
and the addition of the micro
environment which is can which can
include biomechanical
electrical or mechanical properties
which makes up this tissue slash organ
model
um microphysiological systems or organ
on a chip come in white range of sizes
and shapes typically they include human
cells and tissues in three-dimensional
platforms to culture tissue and organ
like structures whereas microfluidics
are Incorporated to mimic blood flow and
delivering oxygen and nutrient
also the microenvironment that these
micro tissues are exposed to can be
optimized to include for example
mechanical or electrical stimulation
and the way that drugs can be introduced
in the system can be controlled in a
matter in a matter to recapitulate the
environment that these tissues
experience in Vivo
so current pre-clinical approaches
produce molecules or therapies
they'll fail 90 of the time in clinical
trials most of the time companies
producing these compounds of unsuspected
drug safety and efficacies issues as you
can also see from these graphs
so what is the current pre-clinical
toolbox for everybody out there
um obviously we have in Silicon computer
modeling um going on we have the 2D cell
cultures
um the 3D spheroid slash organoids that
have been around for a while now and the
golden standard for most of the
pre-clinical testing which is the in
Vivo animal models
but
we also have the new alternative methods
such as the MPS that
can enable researchers to bridge the gap
between current pre-clinical and vitro
and Viva models
that is also supported in in changes to
the regulatory landscape
on the 29th of September 2022 the U.S
Senate unanimously passed bill as 5002
the FDA modernization act 2.0 the
original act mandated that all drugs
must be tested on animals before human
clinical trials on December 23 2022 the
U.S House gave itself gave its final
approval
now drug testing does not need to be
performed on animals anymore this also
paves the way for the use of new
approach methodologies in order to
establish drug safety and Effectiveness
in place of animal testing where
appropriate of course
now let's have a quick look at the
different models that are currently
present
so obviously we have 2D cell culture 3D
spheroids and in Vivo animal models and
our MPS or organ on a chip platform
so obviously the human relevance is
clearly
lower in animal models compared to
organic chip which uses human primary
cells another interesting point would be
the longevity of the of the systems
which 2D cell culture that 3D spheroids
are fairly lower lower on the side
whereas animal models and Organo chips
last for up to four weeks if not longer
um and other interesting fact is the
acute and chronic dosing which can only
occur in in Viva animal models as well
as the organ on a chip and obviously
human relevance
animal model is as good as they are
they're not relevant to humans even if
there are humanized bottles out there
the organic platform on the other side
uses actual human primary cells
um this is our physiomimic system it has
a unique open well design and it's easy
to install and set up with a controller
which Strays outside which stays outside
of the incubator you can set up the flow
flow Direction and flow rates for your
experiment
the plate sits in the driver on the
docking station which sits inside the
standard size incubator a physio mimic
system enables you to model human
biology in the lab through Rapid and
predictive human tissue-based studies
with built-in microfluidic technology to
provide nutrients and mimic blood flow
now it's important to have a look at the
liver architecture and some main cell
types that are included in in the liver
so we have obviously
hepatocytes which is the most abundant
cell type in the liver then we have the
Cup results which are the
cell the the resident immune cells of
the liver as well as the stellate cells
or hepatic cells as otherwise known
and as you can see the intricate
architecture of
um the part of the liver
it's also important to establish which
are the markers to you know to see
self-health or function in liver for
example albumin production is one of the
functional markers that is very useful
in assessing
um functionality in liver cells as well
as urea synthesis phase one and phase
two enzyme expression uh
mostly cytochrome cytochrome enzymes
which are very relevant for xenobiotic
[Music]
um
metabolism sorry
and other transporter expression and
marker of hepatic damage such as alt and
AST
now let's have a look at the actual
um chip
um slash our plate or liver plate we
have an elongated teardrop shaped well
with collagen quoted scaffolds
as you can see here at the bottom which
include multiple pores where the cells
are seeded and the tissues can be formed
the circulation is microfluidic
fluidically driven
and here you can see the morphogenesis
from single cells to micro tissues over
the time course of seven days
um yeah from single cells on day zero to
a fully formed micro tissue day seven
now here we can see some beautiful
immunofluorescent stainings for albumin
for example in the cytoskeleton albumin
as I previously mentioned is a important
hepatic functional marker which is
clearly abundant in our micro tissues as
well as the cytoskeleton which is quite
important in terms of the organ or micro
tissue architecture
we can also see at the bottom left that
bioconiculi are present as well as tight
junctions which
um
which indicates that the hepatocytes are
polarized a very important physiological
attribute of the hepatocytes
so our liver our liver MPS produces
long-term and
High functional mono and cold cultures
here on the left you can see the
electron microscopy image showing the
ballot caniculus with intact
microvilli tight junctions as well as
the Lumen of the canaliculus
and on the top right graphs we can see
that hepatic functionality uh
is good but due to the album in
production indicating the album in
production as well as the cell Health
with low consistent LDH released
throughout the course of 28 days
on the bottom right graph we can see the
expression of various cytochrome enzymes
from different donors and we can see the
variability within the different donors
which will lead us to the next portion
of our presentation
on Cell validation the importance of
cell validation as well
now obviously in in the industry out
there there's a lot of debate in terms
of what cells to use in order to model
disease and the main debate has been
always
human primary souls or animal primary
Cells versus Cell lines or apcs and
obviously cell lines and ipcs are easy
to handle and readily available at a low
cost
and obviously reproduce reproducible
results are ready to go but they're not
genetic stable nor are they human
relevant
human relevance
um
appears to be the best for primary
hepatic cells in in our case at least as
well as genetic stability obviously for
uh primary human primary cells we have
inherent and reduce variability as we
as as it's known in the field
but
um additional difficulties also
have is is the handling of the cell
types of the handling of the cells for
example the hepatocytes are very
sensitive to shear stress
um and obviously the lifespan of um
primary cells in 2D is very poor
and obviously in order to eliminate
the uh eliminate or reduce as much as
possible this inherent or introduced
variability in these cells we've
established cell validation protocols in
order to achieve
um reproducibility and consistency in
our results
so donor selection for donor selection
we need to
um obviously quantify what age is a
donor what the postal availability is
what the lot size is and the genetics
and obviously the the con the
qualification in 3D
so for that what we do is obviously
culture these cells
um and we need to assess micro tissue
formation as you've previously seen in
the other slides the Sip activity the
albumin production the viable cells per
vile as well as the welcome Well to Well
consistency within within one donor
and here at the bottom you can see uh
some
some donors five five different donors
to be exact and as you can see they're
the micro tissue formation is very
variable especially donor E
um shows very poor micro tissue
formation so it's crucial that we
actually test the donors before we start
with any other assays with these cells
or culturing of these cells
so in terms of methodology what we do is
we always start with the primary human
hepatocytes for the validation on their
own as a monoculture and that lasts for
about two weeks and we have five
different time points on these five
different time points we check the
hepatic function and cell Health by
using albumin LDA interior and cp3a4
assays
and for each of these time points we
have specific past criteria and you can
also see the timeline of the experiment
at the bottom as well
now obviously more relevant for the
daily experiments that we're going to
talk later on there are co-cultures that
need to be validated as well so for a
couple for cup for sauce in order for
them to be validated they need to be
co-cultured with pre-validated phhs and
treated with or without
lipopolysaccharides in order to induce
immunological response these experiments
last about five days and liver function
is tested using urea and the
inflammatory responses for the copper
cells are tested using il-6 and tnf
Alpha assays
now in order to validate hepatic stalact
cells we do a triple culture
including pre-validated phhs and cases
and their treat this triple culture with
hepatic cell and cells is treated with
Hep fat medium which is for Nash
induction and whether without TGF beta
for advanced fiber for an advanced
fibrosis phenotype
um the duration of that type of cell
validation culture is around 14 days and
the hepatic function and cell health is
similarly to the other ones using
albumin LDH in urea and here we have the
addition of the Nash phenotype which is
um which is assessed by il-6 Ila tip 1
and fibronectin
now we're going into the portion of a
drug induced liver injury and just to
let you know what we have established so
far in the in the in the daily field is
that we have long-term highly functional
hepatocytes and NPC coal cultures where
we also can do chronic dosing with
multiple endpoints we can generate ic15
and ec50 curves and we can also evaluate
small molecules antibodies and new
modalities
in this uh in this model and obviously
clinical biomarkers such as alt and AST
can also be detected
foreign
is one of the organs most susceptible to
drug toxicity and Dilly and and Dilly is
a major cause of drug failure using more
reliable human in vitro 3D models is an
essential step to de-risk daily and Drug
Discovery so here we demonstrate the use
of our liver MPS platform by co-culture
primary human hepatocytes and copper
cells we are able to administrate
several compounds with different delete
severities or typical study timeline
includes four days of so-called culture
following by four days of dosing of
compound it is vital to perform the cell
quality control prior to the dosing and
during the experiments by using
obviously reliably reliable assays
the data projected at the top are
generated from the entire study in which
the 15 compounds were tested and shows
good levels of reproducibility with low
interestudy variability
in the graphs below
um we after we can see that after an
eight day culture multiple cell health
and hepatic metrics such as albumin
ureas and ATP we're also assessed in
healthy control micro tissues and showed
high level of hepatic functionality and
reproducibility
moment
our first case study presents data for
two
anti-diabetic thiasol leading diadones
troglitazone and pioglitazone
so translator Zone was classified as a
severe daily concern and was licensed
for use in 1997 to treat type 2 diabetes
but was withdrawn by the FDA only three
years later due to the frequency of
liver injury including acute liver
failure reported in the post-marketing
surveillance
moreover to date published animal
studies failed to predict your
medicine's potential to cause severe
liver injury the toxicity of this
compound was also not detected in
standard in richer 2D hepatic assays
Pio glitterzone on the other hand is a
compound known to be of low daily
concern
instances of acute liver injury due to
Pure glitterzone are rare but have been
seen occasionally
specifically for patients with obesity
and heart failure
during its development pure glitter Zone
did not exert any hepatoxicity in
classic in region 2D models
or in more advanced 3D models
and as you can see here from our data an
acute Ox response was detected by Alt
and LDH released when the liver micro
tissues were dosed with roglitazone for
96 hours
furthermore a rapid reduction of albumin
and urea was shown
um as you can see sip 3a4 activity which
is for assessing metabolic
biotransformation also confirmed that
toxicity caused by triglytazol
on the other hand showed multiple toxic
effects with moderate reduction in
albumin and urea production
and very minor reduction in ATP content
was also observed at high publitism
concentrations but this was not
significant
the results demonstrate the ability of
the liver MPS to detect the toxicity of
compounds with my own daily concern
and we can also see here
sorry we can also see here bright filled
Imaging of the form micro tissue treated
with proglitasone after eight days of
culture which also confirms the severe
dose dependent damage of troglitazole as
a positive control we used here called
promising which is a known High toxic uh
hepatotoxic compound
here is a further set of bright filled
microscopy for Pure glitterzone treated
scaffolds which shows slight micro
tissue alteration following the 96r
exposure to the drug at the two highest
concentrations as you can see our system
is sensitive enough to detect the
difference in compounds with varying
daily concern
now our second case study included
tocophone
which are currently used for the
management of Parkinson's disease both
classified as catechol methyl
transferase or comp inhibitors
tocophone was the first comp inhibitor
approved by the FDA and was introduced
to the U.S market in 1998 however it was
withdrawn soon after its approval due to
the death of several patients with a
severe liver complications indicating
that it's still a risk was missed during
the pre-clinical safety testing
talk upon was subsequently reintroduced
to the market in 2009 to be used only as
a last resort treatment for Parkinson's
Disease
and Tuck upon on the other hand is talk
upon structural analog and is the second
comp inhibitor approved for Parkinson's
Disease and has low risk of hepatoxicity
it is therefore considered as relatively
safe but occasionally cause some liver
damage
in vitrocellular assay showed up
both compounds can induce mitochondrial
dysfunction in a dose-dependent manner
or by inhibition of eflex Transporters
but only talk upon was associated with
immune mediated daily
causing a sharp increase in t regulatory
cells whereas antagopone did not exert
an effect of this type of cells
pocophone here in our data caused the
clear acute toxic response that was
detected by clinical biomarker alt and L
alt and LDH release and a rapid
reduction in albumin and urea chronic
exposure was captured also by all tested
endpoints particularly in albumin
as well as cellular endpoints such as
ATP further confirmed talk talk upon's
toxicity
foreign the model did not affect the
cute and chronic toxicity effects
following the treatment
as I previously previously mentioned as
well we we tested also some new
modalities
um we chose Asos or otherwise known as
known as antisense or oligonucleotides
which are engineered molecules that
contain locked nucleic acid or otherwise
called LNA designed to induce Target RNA
cleavage
studies show there there's a strong
association between liver toxicity and
the sequence content of the LNA Gap
mirror of Asus now the liver is one of
the accumulation Target organs where
asomediated toxicity is often observed
in vitro biotransformation studies at an
early stage of drug development are
Paramount for the prediction of
potential hypothetic toxicity of Asos
for modalities such as Asus Asos which
have human specific mode of action
animal Motors models are less suited and
therefore it is imperative to use the
most human translatable in vitro models
available for the preclinical evaluation
to rule out false reporting due to
interspecious differences
so the liver NPS model here
distinguished between safe and toxic
toxic Asos lna32 being the safe in Vivo
and Ln 43 severely hepatotoxic in Vivo
with acute toxic response detected by
only clinical biomarkers alt and LDH
release at 96 hours of exposure as you
can see here in the graphs
interestingly enough the hepatoxicity of
lna43 was not picked up by more
simplistic in vitro human cells cultures
models the data is not shown here but we
hypothesize that the presence of hepatic
immune cells hate the cop results I've
spoken before in the liver micro tissue
is key to the assay's increased
sensitivity whilst our findings
recapitulate the published data from
Individual trials conducted on Mouse and
rack models we recommend the
complementary use of MPS models when
working with human specific modalities
to confirm that data from in Vivo animal
studies
here for each compound a range of
functional liver specific endpoints were
analyzed including clinical biomarkers
those response using multi-chip plates
to generate ec50 curves those functional
liver specific endpoints were analyzed
to create a distinct mechanistic
signature of about toxicity from the
liver MPS to demonstrate its capacity to
assess human delay risk of normal
pharmacological agents to improve the
translational relevance of this model
functional liver specific endpoints were
analyzed including critical biomarkers
such as Alt
the ratio of e EC 50 to plasma C Max or
exposure corrected side toxicity was
determined for each compound and plotted
as the margin of safety called MOS
the MOs value for all tested compounds
were plotted at 96 hours of exposure
tested compounds are shown on the
horizontal axis and are arranged from
low deliciverity to the left to severe
daily concerning concern sorry to the
right at fixed thresholds of 50 times
MOS values the sensitivity and the
specificity of the assay were assessed
by comparing daily positive negative
status
as determined by ec50 or MOS threshold
with known daily status for each
compound
so data indicates that our albumin was
by far the most sensitive assay and
highlights a clear Trend between MOS
values and daily severity the data
demonstrates that the liver MPS daily
assay has Superior sensitivity and
specificity over classic to primary
hepatocytes hepatocyte cultures and in
detecting drug inducible toxicity
just to summarize all the different
messages across this presentation
um it's crucial that we perform cell
validation because we keep the
consistency and the accurate results
across all of our experiments
the liver MPS provides a better in vitro
to in to to in Vivo transitability by
using clinical relevant biomarkers as
we've previously mentioned such as alt
the assay offers advantages over
existing in vitro approaches by
incorporating the immune aspects of the
liver that contribute to dealing
um also we can accurately predict the
non-delia liabilities of a broad set of
compounds of different modalities from
various drugs to Asos as we said
um also it is insightful insightful for
the evaluation of drugs with human
specific models of action where animal
Motors are less suited again the aces
the human relevant Aces that we talked
before
overall by improving the ability to
predict Tilly the daily risks in early
stages the liver MPS can potentially
better protect patients lives and say
save drug Discovery companies companies
huge costs
thank you so much for your attention and
I hope you've learned something feel
free to ask me further questions via
email and I'd like to thank my
colleagues a video Novak already Raul
Silva for providing the data and also
helping me with this presentation thank
you